what do you think about something that's
insured for about a million dollars
howard what did i feel that it's time
you were elevated from fart man to
something uh possibly more heroic okay
would you do me the honor of trying on
my classic original
that
batman
actual one yes do you think i'd fit yes
you didn't blow any schneider into this
did you god no i've kept it clean all
these years does it's a glee let me see
that hold it up now why on the inside
does it say this is not a safety helmet
why does it say that seriously
what it is a safety helmet oh it is oh
yeah if someone wrote on it this is not
a safety helmet uh it's high impact
plastic this is the actual so the people
who are out to get me will read it first
this is the actual batman thing that you
wore on tv yes you know it's funny it it
it doesn't look that elaborate we see it
yeah here it is but however it
photographs like a million dollars at
all look at the little lines look how
cheaply made it
do you know what the value of that is
what
take it because i heard adam talking
about he wants to be really careful with
it notice adam hasn't sold it to anybody
it's worth
300 000 and insured for a million
is it really worth something yes it is
yeah yeah i've had offers for all that
stuff howard really yeah i've got kind
of a small warehouse full of memories do
you have the suit and everything sure i
got like that jacket he wears he wears
it every night before he goes to bed
no no but the point is that you have
that stuff and that's probably
worthwhile in the sense monetarily you
didn't get paid that much for the batman
show so the idea that you held on to
that stuff
was probably the smartest investment you
could have made well i thought uh it was
kind of true yeah right because
here's here's according to the new book
by adam west he made 4 500 a week for
batman
and by the last that was by the last
season oh so that was his big raise only
got paid for reruns for the first two
years in syndication i never made out
any money on the merchandiser
who was your agent
gary dellavedy was your agent i can't
believe it
it just didn't occur to you'd ask for
those things at that time i mean he
didn't make deals like that yeah well
when you first got into it you were
probably happy to have the gig right i
mean at first you were like hey this is
a cool job so i'll do it for a little
bit of money every week yeah and then
you probably signed a long-term contract
and then trying to get more money out of
them was ridiculous right but i think
howard uh what seems like a little bit
of money to you and the others here this
morning uh was considerable money then
oh for what i was doing after all it was
80 years ago right right right
did you flip out when um they gave it to
michael keaton then you weren't even
called well i had about
15 minutes of madness and being crazed
and and uh disappointed right you really
didn't think they were going to put you
in no robin i didn't at all because i
heard about it
you know
right uh i i decided that uh you know
why
i i don't want to be bitter yeah but why
couldn't you play alfred or someone like
that you could certainly do that
been out for us yeah that would have
been good
but uh what i'd would love to do is come
in and play uncle batman uncle batman
right yeah in other words things get so
tense and awful so heinous right right
right
right that uh whoever whoever's playing
batman has to call on me he discovers me
as a working criminologist